Back on one of the early episodes of our radio show, I had my friend Vertamae Grosvenor come on. Verta was this amazing cook. She wrote a cookbook in 1970, Vibration Cooking, that is still in print today. And Verta had this story that she would tell sometimes that, back when her book was published, she was interviewed on the Today show by Barbara Walters, who was on the show back then.
在我们广播节目早期的其中一期，我邀请了我的朋友弗塔梅·格罗夫纳（Vertamae Grosvenor）来做客。弗塔是个了不起的厨师。她在1970年写了一本烹饪书《震动烹饪》（Vibration Cooking），至今仍在印刷。弗塔以前常讲一个故事：当年她的书出版时，芭芭拉·沃尔特斯（Barbara Walters）在当时的《今日秀》（Today）节目中采访了她。
And the way Verta told this story, she's on TV, making fried chicken for Barbara Walters. And at some point, Barbara Walters asked her, how do you tell the chicken's done? And Verta says, you can tell by the sound. And in Verta's telling, Ms. Walters gives her this skeptical look, like, give me a break, and cuts to commercial. Verta said that was always people's reaction.
在弗塔讲述的版本里，她当时在电视上为芭芭拉·沃尔特斯炸鸡。做到一半时，芭芭拉·沃尔特斯问她：“你怎么知道鸡肉熟了没？”弗塔回答：“听声音就能听出来。”而在弗塔的讲述中，沃尔特斯女士露出了那种怀疑的眼神，好像在说“得了吧”，然后就切入广告了。弗塔说，那总是人们的反应。
They say, you're crazy, Verta. That's not it. They said, tell me something real, like, what is it? 15 minutes, 20 minutes, or whatever. And I say, you've got to listen to the sound of the grease. Listen to the music.
他们会说：“你疯了，弗塔。根本不是那样。”他们说：“告诉我点实在的，比如那是多久？15分钟，20分钟，还是别的什么？”而我说：“你得听油的声音。听那种音乐。”
So for years, Vertamae claimed that you can tell if a chicken's done purely by the sound. And to prove the point, she agreed to come onto our radio show to conduct this little radio experiment, where my co-workers and I fried a chicken. and we recorded it at four different stages of frying, and then shuffled the order of the recordings to play for Verta to demonstrate, once and for all, was it true? Can somebody tell if a chicken's cooked without any visual clues, without smell?
多年来，弗塔梅一直坚称，完全可以通过声音判断鸡肉是否熟了。为了证明这一点，她同意来到我们的广播节目进行一次小小的广播实验：我和同事们炸了一只鸡，我们录下了油炸过程中的四个不同阶段，然后打乱录音顺序播放给弗塔听，想要一劳永逸地证明：这是真的吗？有人能在没有任何视觉线索、没有任何嗅觉的情况下判断鸡肉是否熟了吗？
OK, and so here is me playing the four recordings for Verta and her trying to pick out which one is the chicken when it's finished.
好，接下来是我为弗塔播放四段录音，让她尝试挑选出哪一段是鸡肉炸好时的声音。
Let's roll. And our listeners at home can play along with us here. Let's roll the first little sample sound.
开始吧。在家收听的听众也可以和我们一起参与。让我们播放第一段声音样本。
[SIZZLING]
[滋滋声]
I would say--
我会说——
Yeah?
嗯？
I'd say that's something like the middle.
我会说那大概是中间阶段。
OK. But that definitely isn't towards the end, you're saying.
好的。但你说那绝对不是接近结尾的时候。
Yeah, it's in the middle going toward the end. It's in the 3/4 part.
是的，它是从中间走向结尾。是在四分之三的部分。
OK, let's hear sound number two, please.
好，请听第二段声音。
[FASTER SIZZLING]
[更快的滋滋声]
Number two is toward the end, too.
第二段也是接近结尾。
OK, number three.
好的，第三段。
[HARSH SIZZLING]
[刺耳的滋滋声]
I think that's the beginning, more toward the beginning.
我认为那是开始阶段，更偏向开始的时候。
That is more toward the beginning. And number four?
那确实更偏向开始的时候。那第四段呢？
[SLOWER SIZZLING]
[较慢的滋滋声]
That's an ender. That's toward the end.
那是最后阶段。那是接近结尾的声音。
OK.
好的。
When all those little balls are forming on the bottom, those little, nice, crusty--
当所有那些小油珠在底部形成时，那些漂亮的、酥脆的……
Now, Verta, if you would have to hazard a guess as to which one would be the very last one--
现在，弗塔，如果你必须猜一下哪一个是最后的一段——
I'd still say it's one or two that's toward the end.
我还是会说是第一段或第二段，是接近结尾的。
The answer is number two, so Vertamae came reasonably close. But she was not totally certain. Telling if a chicken is done only by sound turned out to be harder than she thought it to be.
答案是第二段，所以弗塔梅猜得相当接近。但她并不完全确定。仅仅通过声音来判断鸡肉是否熟了，结果比她想象的要难。
Yes, it was hard. You have to see it. Do you know what I mean?
是的，这很难。你必须亲眼看到它。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah.
嗯。
Oh, it's a serious-- it's a labor-intensive thing. You've got to stay on it. You just can't be talking on the phone and watching TV. You got to stay on that chicken.
哦，这是一件严肃的、耗费体力的事。你必须守着它。你不能一边打电话一边看电视。你得一直盯着那只鸡。
I was asking your daughters today, and they were saying how they can also tell if rice is done by the sound.
我今天问了你的女儿们，她们说她们也能通过声音判断米饭是否熟了。
Oh, yeah, that's true. Yeah, I taught them that. Those are the kind of family values I taught my children. Listen to the sound of the chicken.
哦，是的，那是真的。是我教她们的。这就是我教给孩子们的家庭价值观。听鸡肉的声音。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You know? Listen to the sound of the rice.
你知道吗？听米饭的声音。
Vertamae died four years ago. And so I have to say, it got to me a little, listening to this next part of the interview where she talks about her daughters, and how happy it made her to hear what they said about her.
弗塔梅四年前去世了。所以不得不说，听到采访的这一部分，听她谈论她的女儿们，以及听到她们谈论她时，她是多么高兴，这让我有些触动。
You talked to both of them?
你和她们两个都聊过了？
I talked to both of them.
我都聊过了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
They were both really funny. One of them said, "Everything that she cooks is golden brown and perfect, perfect, perfect."
她们俩真的很有趣。其中一个说：“她做的每一道菜都是金黄酥脆，完美、完美、完美。”
Who said that?
谁说的？
I believe it was Chandra.
我想是钱德拉（Chandra）。
Really?
真的吗？
But she said, "But just because we're her daughters, that doesn't mean that she tells us the real recipes. We ask her for the recipes and she tells us recipes. But then when we cook them, they're not the same, and we know that she's holding back on ingredients."
但她说：“但这并不意味着因为我们是她的女儿，她就会告诉我们真正的食谱。我们向她要食谱，她也给我们食谱。但当我们照着做的时候，味道却不一样，我们知道她在配料上留了一手。”
Well, that's not quite true. But you know--
嗯，那不太准确。但你知道——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, now, I just tell them. But then they have to find out the rest for themselves.
好吧，我现在确实告诉了她们。但剩下的得靠她们自己去发现。
There you go.
原来如此。
You see what I'm saying?
你明白我的意思吗？
As with so many things in parenting.
就像育儿中的许多事情一样。
I say, I put a little ginger in. Now, I'm not going-- then they have to figure out how much a little ginger is.
我说，我放了一点姜。好吧，我不打算——所以她们得自己琢磨出“一点”姜是多少。
Yeah.
嗯。
That's what they have to do.
她们就得这样做。
Food, of course, really is everything. It's family, and it's culture, and it's tradition. It's improvisation and it's art. And today on our show, for Thanksgiving weekend, we put together a show made of stories we've done over the years about food. In every one of these stories, somebody heads out on a quest, either to figure something out or to do something very differently with food than most of us do. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
食物，当然，确实就是一切。它是家庭，是文化，是传统。它是即兴创作，是艺术。今天在我们的节目中，为了感恩节周末，我们整理了一期节目，由我们多年来制作的关于食物的故事组成。在每一个故事里，都有人踏上一段探寻之旅，要么是为了搞清楚某件事，要么是在食物上做一些与我们大多数人非常不同的尝试。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这里是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, "Dead Ringer." So a few years back, one of our producers, Ben Calhoun, set out on a mission much more eccentric and labor-intensive than figuring out if a chicken is done by listening to the sound. Here he is.
第一幕，“冒牌货”。几年前，我们的制片人之一本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）开始了一项比“听声音判断鸡肉熟没熟”更加古怪且费力的任务。他来了。
I first heard about this whole thing in an email. It came from a listener, a woman named Emily Rancer. She works in the food industry. And the letter Emily wrote was about a story she'd heard from a farmer. The farmer who told her this is apparently a person of some standing in the pork industry. And admittedly, I don't know the first thing about the pork industry. But he's in charge of a pork-producing operation that spans several states.
我第一次听到整件事是在一封电子邮件里。它来自一位听众，名叫艾米丽·兰瑟（Emily Rancer）。她在食品行业工作。艾米丽写的信是关于她从一位农民那里听来的故事。告诉她这个故事的农民显然在猪肉行业有一定的地位。不得不承认，我对猪肉行业一无所知。但他负责一个跨越好几个州的猪肉生产业务。
The story he told Emily went something like this. A while ago, he was visiting a pork processing plant in Oklahoma. He's walking through it with a friend, a guy who managed the plant, actually. And at some point, he saw boxes stacked on the floor labeled, artificial calamari. He stood there, wondering for a second. And then he asked his friend, what's artificial calamari? Bung, his friend replied. It's hog rectum, rectum that would be sliced into rings, deep fried, and boom, there you have it.
他告诉艾米丽的故事大概是这样的：不久前，他去参观俄克拉荷马州的一家猪肉加工厂。他和朋友一起走在厂里，那个朋友其实是工厂的经理。在某个点，他看到地上堆着标有“人造鱿鱼圈”的箱子。他站在那里，疑惑了一秒钟。然后他问朋友：“什么是人造鱿鱼圈？”“Bung（直肠），”朋友回答。“那是猪的直肠，切成圈后油炸，砰，就是这样。”
OK, if I can, let me just narrate for you what this would mean. It would mean that in restaurants everywhere, right this second, people are squeezing lemon wedges over crispy, golden rings and dipping the rings into marinara sauce, and they're eating hog rectum. Now they're chewing, satisfied and deeply clueless. It's payback. It's payback for our blissful ignorance about where our food comes from and how it gets to us. It's amazing, and it's perfect.
好了，如果可以的话，让我为你描述一下这意味着什么。这意味着在各地的餐馆里，就在这一秒，人们正在香脆的金黄色圆圈上挤柠檬汁，蘸着番茄酱吃，而他们吃的是猪直肠。他们正在咀嚼，感到满足而且完全被蒙在鼓里。这是报应。这是我们对食物来源及其处理方式盲目无知所受的报应。这太惊人了，简直完美。
But it also seems like it couldn't possibly be true. So I called up the farmer to talk to him personally, I wanted to hear it firsthand. And the farmer confirmed the story, the entire thing-- the boxes, the bung. But when I asked him to go on the record, to tape an interview and give his name here on the radio, he very politely declined, which seems suspicious, right? When I asked him why, he said he'd spoken with his girlfriend about it, and she suggested that he should think about the words that he wanted to come up when somebody googled his name.
但这听起来也不可能是真的。所以我打电话给那位农民，想亲自跟他聊聊，我想听听第一手消息。农民证实了这个故事，整件事——箱子，直肠。但当我要求他公开记录，录音并在广播里说出他的名字时，他非常礼貌地拒绝了，这看起来很可疑，对吧？当我问他为什么时，他说他跟女朋友谈过这件事，她建议他应该考虑一下，当别人谷歌搜索他的名字时，他希望会出现什么样的评价。
This was all fine, though, because he referred me to the real expert, the guy who gave him the tour of the hog processing plant. And that guy, he agreed to talk.
不过这一切都好，因为他把我介绍给了真正的专家，那个带他参观猪肉加工厂的人。那个人，他同意谈谈。
[PHONE RINGS]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
喂？
Hi. Is this Ron?
你好。是罗恩吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, this is Ron Meek, meat processing plant manager, presently residing in Mountain View, Missouri, where he runs an organic beef processing plant there called Beyond Organic. If the story really were true, Ron would have been the guy who explained to the farmer what was in those boxes.
是，我是罗恩·米克（Ron Meek），肉类加工厂经理，目前住在密苏里州山景城，他在那里经营一家名为“超越有机”（Beyond Organic）的有机牛肉加工厂。如果这个故事是真的，罗恩就是那个向农民解释箱子里装的是什么的人。
The boxes are 10-pound boxes. And they were all-- they cut off so much, like, maybe a 10 or 12-inch piece of the bung. And you know what it looks like? This looks like-- after they're cleaned, and washed, and everything, they just look like a bunch of big noodles in a box is all it looks like.
那些箱子是10磅重的。它们都被——切掉了很多，大概12英寸长的直肠。你知道它看起来像什么吗？在清洗干净之后，它们看起来就像一箱子大面条，仅此而已。
But specifically, the labels that said "imitation calamari," where did you personally see the imitation calamari labels?
但具体来说，那些写着“仿鱿鱼”的标签，你本人是在哪里看到的？
Oh, I've never seen a label say that. That's all I was told by the people that told me that. The people I worked for, they told me that.
哦，我从来没见过写着那个的标签。那都是告诉我这事的人说的。我为之工作的人，他们告诉我的。
Oh, the people that you worked for told you that it was used for imitation calamari?
哦，雇佣你的人告诉你它是用来做仿鱿鱼的？
Right.
是的。
And is there any possibility that you think that when they were explaining this to you that they were kind of having you on a little bit?
有没有可能，当他们向你解释的时候，他们是在开你的玩笑？
Having me on?
开我的玩笑？
Yeah, like--
是啊，就像——
Bull-[BLEEP] me?
胡扯我？
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
[笑声] 是啊。
Well, I wouldn't think that. But you know, it could be 5%. It could have been that, you know? But I seriously doubt it.
嗯，我不觉得。但你知道，可能有5%的几率吧。可能是那样。但我严重怀疑。
OK, just to give a little better picture, a pork bung-- and bung is the actual industry term for it-- is long, and floppy, and ugly. At one end, it widens out into this more bulbous shape, like a pink, wrinkly pear. That's the rectum. At the other end, it narrows into a soft, pinkish-white tube. I know. It sounds gross.
好的，为了更清楚地说明一下，猪直肠——直肠（Bung）是业内术语——又长、又软、又丑。一端变宽成球状，像个粉红色的、皱巴巴的梨。那是直肠。另一端变细，形成一个柔软的粉白色管子。我知道，听起来很恶心。
But also, consider we are a nation that eats more than a billion pounds of sausage every year-- billion, with a B. Maybe you like liverwurst, or capicola, or summer sausage with a natural casing. Then you, like me, have eaten bung-- stuffed, dried bung. A lot of brats and Italian sausages are stuffed in intestine. So if you eat those regularly, you pretty much live up the street from bung.
但同时考虑到我们国家每年消费超过10亿磅香肠——10亿，带B开头的。也许你喜欢肝泥香肠、意式熟火腿，或者带有天然肠衣的夏季香肠。那么，像我一样，你吃过直肠——灌装的、干燥的直肠。很多德国小香肠和意大利香肠都是塞在肠子里做的。所以如果你经常吃那些，你基本上就和直肠住得很近。
So why does the idea of a fried ring of bung just feel grosser? Well, partly, it's the visual, right? When you see that little ring of calamari, you don't want to picture it in the context of a pig's behind. Then there are all the people who don't eat pork, period. Ron said there's also another reason.
那为什么炸直肠圈听起来更恶心呢？好吧，部分原因是视觉效果，对吧？当你看到那个小小的鱿鱼圈时，你不想把它想象成猪屁股。此外，还有很多人根本不吃猪肉。罗恩说还有另一个原因。
Just because of the word bung, probably. People don't just want to jump up and say, man, I'm going to eat me some bung tonight. That's just the way it is.
大概只是因为“直肠”这个词。人们不想直接跳起来说：“伙计，我今晚要吃点直肠。”事实就是这样。
But the big question, the question you've been thinking about since we got on this topic, have you or I eaten imitation calamari, bung dressed up as seafood? Well, Ron didn't know. He said his plant exported a lot of their bung to Asia. But he just didn't know much about whatever happened after it left the door, so he could only speculate. Anything, he said, would be a wild guess.
但最大的问题，也是我们谈到这个话题时你一直在思考的问题，你或我吃过“仿鱿鱼”吗？把直肠伪装成海鲜？好吧，罗恩不知道。他说他的工厂把很多直肠出口到了亚洲。但他对这些东西离开工厂之后发生了什么了解不多，所以他只能猜测。他说，任何说法都只是猜测。
So I turned to people who would know. Is pork bung being falsely peddled as calamari? I called the USDA. The USDA's food inspection service issued the following statement to me. "Products we inspect, including those derived from pork, must be accurately labeled and cannot purport to be a product of another species."
所以我求助于那些知情人士。猪直肠真的被伪造成鱿鱼兜售吗？我打电话给美国农业部。美国农业部食品检验局向我发表了以下声明：“我们检验的产品，包括猪肉制品，必须准确贴标，且不得冒充其他物种的产品。”
So it's against the rules, but people break the rules. A recent study of seafood by a group called Oceana used DNA testing and found that all across the country, fish is regularly being labeled as other species in restaurants and in grocery stores-- escolar sold as white tuna, Pacific rockfish being fraudulently sold as snapper.
所以这是违规的，但人们会打破规则。最近由“Oceana”组织进行的一项海鲜研究使用了DNA测试，发现全国范围内的餐厅和杂货店里，鱼类经常被贴上其他物种的标签——用 escolar 冒充白金枪鱼，用太平洋石斑鱼冒充鲷鱼。
In Miami, more than 30% of fish was being sold as something it wasn't. In New York, the number was 39%. Boston, 48%. Los Angeles-- are you ready? 55%. 55%. That means if you order fish in LA, you are most likely eating a species you did not order.
在迈阿密，超过30%的鱼类名不副实。在纽约，这个数字是39%。波士顿是48%。洛杉矶——准备好了吗？55%。55%。这意味着如果你在洛杉矶点鱼，你很有可能吃到的是你并没有点的物种。
In other words, seafood substitution is rampant in this country. And depending on where you live, from what I can tell, you can get cleaned hog bung for about half the price of clean squid. So there would be money in it, if you could pull off the switch. And as best as I can tell, were you to do this, you would not be caught.
换句话说，在这个国家，海鲜替换现象非常猖獗。根据你的居住地，据我所知，你可以以清洁鱿鱼价格的一半买到清洁的猪直肠。所以如果能完成这种调包，是有利可图的。而且据我所知，如果你这样做，是不太会被抓到的。
A lawyer who's familiar with this area of law and regulation told me, once bung leaves the plant, there is a variety of agencies and entities that would be in play-- USDA, FDA, state and local government. But ultimately, he said, the regulation we have is not designed to catch an offense like this. It's aimed mostly at sanitation and food safety. So bottom line, the lawyer said, if somebody wanted to do it, chances are they'd get away with it.
一位熟悉这一法律和监管领域的律师告诉我，一旦直肠离开工厂，就会涉及各种机构和实体——美国农业部、食品药品监督管理局、州和地方政府。但他说，最终，现有的监管设计并不是为了抓住这类违规行为。它主要针对的是卫生和食品安全。所以底线是，律师说，如果有人想这么干，他们很有可能逃脱惩罚。
So is someone out there doing this? Well, for weeks, I looked for an answer. The USDA says they've never heard of anyone trying to pass pork bung as squid or any other species.
那么外面有人在做这种事吗？嗯，几周来，我一直在寻找答案。美国农业部表示，他们从未听说过有人试图把猪直肠当成鱿鱼或其他物种。
[PHONE RINGS]
[电话铃声]
I contacted the National Restaurant Association, the National Pork Producers Council, the National Pork Board--
我联系了全国餐馆协会、全国猪肉生产商委员会、全国猪肉委员会——
Hello?
喂？
--a squid fishermen's association--
——鱿鱼渔民协会——
Good afternoon, National Pork Board.
下午好，全国猪肉委员会。
--Sysco and other big food and restaurant supply companies.
——Sysco和其他大型食品和餐馆供应公司。
It's hog what?
猪什么？
Bung. Hog rectum.
直肠。猪肛门。
Oh my gosh.
我的天。
That's the executive director of the California Wetfish Producers Association. But the answer was pretty much always the same, nobody had heard of it. But almost to a person, they added that that doesn't mean it's not happening somewhere.
那是加州湿鱼生产商协会的执行主任。但答案几乎总是相同的，没人听说过。但几乎每个人都补充说，这并不意味着它在某些地方没有发生。
Ron Meeks said a lot of the bung from his plant got exported. So my next call was to the US Meat Export Federation, which confirmed that, quote, "The main destinations for pork bungs are China, Hong Kong, Japan, Taiwan, Korea, and the Philippines. They are mainly used for processing, but we are aware of some uses in soups and certain entrees. We are not aware of them being used as a substitute for calamari, but it's not impossible," unquote.
罗恩·米克斯说他工厂里的很多直肠都出口了。所以我下一个电话打给了美国肉类出口联合会，他们证实道：“猪直肠的主要目的地是中国、香港、日本、台湾、韩国和菲律宾。它们主要用于加工，但我们意识到它们在汤和某些菜肴中有一些用途。我们不知道它们被用作鱿鱼的替代品，但这并非不可能。”
So over the past few weeks, I've called Asian food suppliers, people who live in, work in, and eat in those countries. I talked to a woman named Corinne Trang, who's written an overarching compendium of Asian cuisines. I've talked to academics at NYU, and Haverford, and USC, and Harvard. I've reached out to chefs who know Asian food. The answer, again, always similar-- never heard of it, but it's possible, partly because bung doesn't have such a complicated reputation in Asia where it has to be some kind of secret ingredient, like it does here.
所以在过去几周里，我打电话给亚洲食品供应商，那些生活在、工作在、吃在这些国家的人。我跟一个叫科琳·特朗（Corinne Trang）的女士聊过，她写过一本亚洲烹饪全集。我跟纽约大学、哈弗福德学院、南加州大学和哈佛大学的学者聊过。我联系了了解亚洲食物的厨师。答案依然相似——从未听说过，但有可能，部分原因是直肠在亚洲的名声并不复杂，它不需要像在这里一样成为某种秘密配料。
On the other hand, though, people pointed out that in Korea and Japan, you can't get more than a few hours from the ocean. Squid is cheap and it's readily available. You'd only eat a substitute if you wanted the substitute. Generally, people said, if the switch was happening somewhere, they guessed China.
另一方面，人们指出，在韩国和日本，你离海洋不超过几个小时的路程。鱿鱼很便宜，而且很容易买到。只有在你想吃替代品时，你才会吃替代品。总的来说，人们说如果这种替换发生在某个地方，他们猜是中国。
Eventually, I found my way to this guy who I was really excited about, someone who I thought might have my answer. He was-- get this-- an anthropologist who lived and worked in China for 40 years where he studied food, and specifically, meat. When I talked to him, though, he made two points.
最终，我找到了我一直很期待的人，我想他可能有答案。他居然是一位在亚洲生活和工作了40年的研究食物，特别是肉类的社会人类学家。当我跟他谈话时，他提出了两点。
Point one, my question about this happening in Asia was racist. Even just asking the question was racist because it plays on ignorant stereotypes about other cultures eating things that we perceive as weird.
第一点，我关于这在亚洲发生的问题是种族主义的。仅仅提出这个问题就是种族主义，因为它利用了关于其他文化吃我们认为奇怪的东西的无知刻板印象。
Point two was that Ron Meek, my guy from the pig plant, Ron was pulling my leg. And he was getting away with it because I was a dumbass. He told me more than once that I should, quote, "find something worthwhile to do with myself." When we ended our conversation, he told me that he was refusing to even dignify what I was doing by appearing on the radio or by letting me use his name.
第二点是罗恩·米克，我在猪肉厂的朋友，是在开我的玩笑。而他能得逞是因为我是个傻瓜。他不止一次告诉我，我应该“找点有意义的事情做”。当我们结束谈话时，他告诉我，他甚至拒绝通过在电台露面或让我使用他的名字来给予这种行为任何正当性。
OK, so to respond to his points one by one, first, am I racist against Asians? Well, I'm half-Chinese. My mom's Chinese. Like anyone, I've had the occasional issue with my mother, but this has not been one of them. We grew up eating chicken feet and fish eyes, and I think it's possible to raise the question of who eats what without being racist.
好吧，回应他的观点。第一，我是种族主义者吗？嗯，我是混血儿，我妈是中国人。像任何人一样，我和我妈偶尔会有摩擦，但这绝不是其中之一。我们从小吃鸡爪和鱼眼，我认为提出谁吃什么的问题并不等同于种族主义。
His second point, though, that Ron Meek was pulling my leg-- the guy was still an expert on meat in China. So I called Ron back.
他的第二点，罗恩·米克在开我玩笑——那家伙依然是中国的肉类专家。所以我打回给罗恩。
All right, shoot me some questions, dude.
好，尽管问吧，伙计。
I told him the whole thing, about the anthropologist, about what he said.
我告诉了他整件事，关于那个社会人类学家，关于他说的内容。
I guess, the only thing I want to ask you is are you messing with me?
我猜，我想问你的唯一一件事是，你是在耍我吗？
No. That was what my boss told me. I was like, what the hell do we save these hog bungs for? He says, they use them for imitation squid and stuff like that.
不。那就是我老板告诉我的。我说，我们要这些猪直肠干什么？他说，他们用它做仿鱿鱼之类的东西。
But so in your heart of hearts, you believe it.
但你在内心深处，你是相信的。
Yeah, man. I ain't going to set here and tell you things that are bull-[BLEEP] and play with you when I'm just going off of my knowledge of saving hog bungs. You got to think about how far advanced slaughterhouses are, especially big ones, that want to make every penny count.
是的，伙计。我不会坐在这里告诉你胡扯的东西，也不会在只基于我知道猪直肠的用途的情况下玩弄你。你得想想屠宰场有多先进，尤其是大型屠宰场，他们想让每一分钱都发挥价值。
Like the one I worked at, you bring the pigs in. You stun them, then you stick them. And the blood goes off into a trough. And it goes down, and it's vacuum sucked out of there with a vacuum into centrifuges. And they separate the blood from the blood plasma.
就像我工作的那家，你把猪赶进去。电晕它们，然后刺穿。血流进槽里。然后通过真空吸入离心机。他们把血从血浆中分离出来。
Mhm.
嗯。
And they save that. They save the lungs. They save the pancreas. They save the spleens. They save the hearts. The only thing left, by the time it's all said and done, is a skull and jaw bones. You can be an anthropologist all you want. If you don't work in a processing plant, you don't know [BLEEP].
他们保存这些。他们保存肺、胰腺、脾脏、心脏。到最后唯一剩下的就是头骨和颌骨。你爱当什么社会人类学家都行。如果你不在加工厂工作，你什么都不懂。
I contacted the plant Ron worked at where this happened. And for what it's worth, they backed him up. They said their sales team had heard of people eating pork bung as imitation calamari, though they hadn't witnessed it firsthand or heard it directly from a customer. It was all hearsay.
我联系了罗恩工作的工厂。值得一提的是，他们支持他。他们说他们的销售团队确实听说过人们吃猪直肠冒充鱿鱼，尽管他们没有亲眼见过，也没有直接从客户那里听到。这都是道听途说。
So at the end of all this, I still had no proof that anyone was passing off bung as squid. Then I realized, I hadn't asked the more basic question here. Could bung do it? Could it pass as calamari?
所以这一切结束时，我依然没有证据证明有人在把直肠当鱿鱼卖。然后我意识到，我还没问最基本的问题。直肠能做到吗？它能冒充鱿鱼吗？
And that question led me to a guy named Eddie Lin. Eddie Lin has eaten a lot of bung. At least a hundred times, he said, probably more. Eddie has an extreme food blog called Deep End Dining and an online TV show called Kamikaze Kitchen.
这个问题把我带到了一个叫埃迪·林（Eddie Lin）的人那里。埃迪·林吃过很多直肠。他说至少一百次，可能更多。埃迪有一个名为“Deep End Dining”的极限美食博客，还有一个名为“Kamikaze Kitchen”的在线电视节目。
I could definitely see a resemblance texturewise.
我确实能看出纹理上的相似之处。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah, yeah, definitely. They're sort of a rubbery texture, sort of like a calamari.
是的，是的，绝对。它们有一种橡胶般的质地，有点像鱿鱼。
Huh.
哈。
But you would really have to get rid of that, needless to say, foul flavor and odor from the bung.
但不用说，你真的必须去除掉直肠那种臭味。
Somehow, I hadn't figured that the bung, once it was scrubbed, and rinsed, and cleaned with steam, that it would still taste like-- you know.
不知何故，我没想到直肠在经过擦洗、漂洗和蒸汽清洁后，还会尝起来——你知道。
So yeah, you would definitely have to do some major, major blanching [LAUGHS] or brining. I meant brining, yeah.
所以是的，你绝对必须进行大规模的漂烫[笑声]或者盐水浸泡。我是说盐水浸泡。
Mhm. Just to try to leach those flavors out of there.
嗯。只是为了把那些味道滤出来。
Yeah, those flavors have been marinating in that pig for quite a while, so--
是的，那些味道在猪身上腌制了很久，所以——
A lifetime.
一生。
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
是的。[笑声]
He thought it wouldn't be easy, but he thought it could be done. And there was only one way to tell if he was right, to cook up some bung and eat it. And if the taste was overwhelming and the texture was all wrong, well, then I'd have my answer. And at this point-- I'll be frank-- I started to root for the bung.
他认为这不容易，但他认为这可以做到。只有一个办法来验证他是对的，那就是做点直肠吃吃看。如果味道令人难以接受，而且口感完全不对，好吧，那我就有答案了。在这一点上——我坦白说——我开始为直肠加油了。
I realized that this is not a story about fraud. It's not a bait-and-switch story. It's a story about possibility. It's classic rags-to-riches. It's about whether a cut of meat, perhaps the lowliest, most malignable cut of meat in America, might somehow, in at least one place on the planet, be dipped in the redemptive oils of the great culinary equalizer that is the deep fryer.
我意识到，这不是一个关于欺诈的故事。这不是一个诱导切换的故事。这是一个关于可能性的故事。这是经典的咸鱼翻身。这关乎一种肉类，也许是美国最卑微、最受诟病的肉类，是否可能在地球上的某个地方，沉浸在深炸锅这种伟大的烹饪平权者的救赎油中。
And it might emerge transformed, no longer an outcast, but instead, hair combed, clean shaven, in a suit and tie, it might walk reborn onto a table. Through shear force of resemblance, it might be loved. Its history, years of drudgery and hardship, doing the body's least glamorous job all washed away.
它可能脱胎换骨，不再是一个被遗忘的弃儿，而是头发梳得整整齐齐，剃了胡子，穿着西装打着领带，重获新生走上餐桌。通过外表的巨大相似性，它可能被人喜爱。它的历史，多年来的苦役和苦难，做着身体上最不迷人的工作，一切都被洗刷干净了。
No, this is not the story of a conman like Bernie Madoff. It's Pretty Woman. This is whether Goodwill Hunting finds his way out of Southie. It's whether Charlie, on that very last chocolate bar, really can get a golden ticket.
不，这不是伯纳德·麦道夫那样的骗子的故事。这是《风月俏佳人》。这是《心灵捕手》找到走出贫民区出路的故事。这是查理在最后一根巧克力棒里是否真的能得到金奖券的故事。
To do all this, to try it, I called my little sister, Lauren. She's a chef, trained abroad at the Cordon Bleu. Worked at Michelin star restaurants. She's that kind of chef. Soon, we were standing in front of a deli case. And I don't know why I feel hesitant about saying this, because I don't think it's racist. It was in Chinatown.
为了做这一切，为了尝试一下，我给我的妹妹劳伦打了电话。她是一名厨师，在蓝带学院受过专业训练。在米其林星级餐厅工作过。她是那种水平的厨师。很快，我们站在一个熟食柜前。我不知道为什么我对说出这一点感到犹豫，因为我不觉得这是种族主义。它在唐人街。
Pork bung, there it is. Look at it. It looks like the sphincter.
猪直肠，就在那儿。看看它。它看起来像括约肌。
Wait. What do you mean it looks like a--
等等。你是什么意思它看起来像个——
This one up here that's cut up, it looks like a butt hole. [LAUGHS]
上面这个切开的，它看起来像个屁眼。[笑声]
It does.
确实。
And Lauren had theories about pulling it off-- brining, soaking, maybe braising. But once we got to the store, once she'd seen the meat up close, her doubts got worse.
劳伦对如何做到这一点有理论——用盐水浸泡，浸泡，也许炖煮。但一旦我们到了商店，一旦她近距离看到肉，她的怀疑就加深了。
I think after looking at it, I don't think that-- I don't think it's going to--
我想看完之后，我不觉得——我不觉得它会成功。
You don't think it's going to work.
你觉得它不会成功。
No. It's too thick. There's too much-- there's too much, like, muscle tissue. It's too thick. You'd have to use a ring cutter to make it the right thickness.
不。它太厚了。肌肉组织太多了。它太厚了。你必须用环形切割器把它做成正确的厚度。
What do you think those bits are in there?
你觉得里面那些东西是什么？
Oh, you know, poo.
哦，你知道，屎。
My sister said Eddie Lin was definitely right. The giveaway would be the stubborn flavor of poo. That flavor, she said, it's tough to get rid of. The Earth revolves around the Sun, and bung will always taste like [BLEEP].
我妹妹说埃迪·林绝对是对的。暴露它的会是顽固的屎味。她说，那种味道很难去除。地球绕着太阳转，而直肠永远尝起来像[哔声]。
But there was no backing out now. We would eat. We would eat our way to the truth. And so what if it didn't look good? So what if bung was destined to taste like bung? You know who it didn't look good for, and he still put up a fight? Rocky Balboa, that's who. This was it, the bung versus calamari, squid versus tail, the rumble in the bung hole.
但现在没有退路了。我们要吃。我们要吃出真相。那么如果它看起来不好看又怎样？如果直肠注定尝起来像直肠又怎样？你知道谁看起来不好看，但他依然奋力一搏吗？洛奇·巴尔博亚（Rocky Balboa），就是他。就是这样，直肠对阵鱿鱼，鱿鱼对阵猪屁股，直肠里的激烈搏斗。
We set up the tasting at a restaurant, in the lull between lunch and dinner. In the dining room, there was just a few tables eating. And all around the restaurant, the morning shift was wrapping up as we walked in with a red cooler filled with squid and hog bung.
我们将试吃安排在一家餐馆，在午餐和晚餐之间的空档。餐厅里只有几桌人在用餐。当我们带着装满鱿鱼和猪直肠的红色冷藏箱走进去时，餐馆里的早班员工正在收尾。
So originally, I'd recruited some half a dozen people from our office at This American Life as tasters. The final group the day of the tasting included, from the office, Seth Lind and Brian Reed.
最初，我从我们的《美国生活》办公室召集了大约半打人作为试吃员。试吃当天的最终小组包括来自办公室的塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）和布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）。
So when's the last time that you guys had calamari?
你们上次吃鱿鱼是什么时候？
I had calamari probably like a month ago.
我大概一个月前吃过鱿鱼。
And what about you, Brian?
你呢，布莱恩？
I haven't had it since we got this tip about the possible--
我自从收到这个关于可能的提示后就没吃过了——
Oh, my gosh. Have you been avoiding?
我的天。你一直在避免吗？
Yeah, no, totally. And to be honest, I ate calamari pretty-- I'm a regular eater of calamari. Not like all the time. But it's something I'll routinely order if it's on an appetizer menu. Yeah.
是啊，完全是。说实话，我经常吃鱿鱼——我是一个经常吃鱿鱼的人。不是说一直吃。但如果开胃菜菜单上有，我通常会点。是的。
I grew up in an Italian-American family, where my grandparents were also born here. I feel like calamari is just big among that sector of people, at Olive Garden and stuff like that. So I just grew up eating it, you know?
我在一个意大利裔美国人家庭长大，我的祖父母也出生在这里。我觉得鱿鱼在那类人中很大众，像橄榄花园（Olive Garden）之类的地方。所以我从小就吃，你知道吗？
I hadn't realized this. For weeks, Brian had been avoiding calamari. He'd been living in fear.
我没意识到这一点。几周来，布莱恩一直在避免吃鱿鱼。他一直生活在恐惧中。
Brian, if you find out that they're indiscernible from each other, will you ever eat calamari again?
布莱恩，如果你发现它们之间无法分辨，你还会再吃鱿鱼吗？
No, I don't think so. That's why I want to do this, just to know going forward.
不，我不觉得。这就是为什么我想这么做，只是为了今后有个底。
Back in the kitchen, things were looking bad. I'd given up on the idea that bung would taste the same as calamari. Now I'd hung my hopes on the idea that, at least visually, it would look the same. But as my sister dropped the floured rings of hog bung into the fryer, they had turned into this kind of big, ugly, tangled wad-- nothing like the jiggly squid rings.
在厨房里，情况看起来很糟糕。我已经放弃了直肠尝起来和鱿鱼一样的想法。现在我把希望寄托在视觉上，希望它看起来是一样的。但当我的妹妹把裹了面粉的猪直肠圈放进油炸锅时，它们变成了那种又大、又丑、纠缠在一起的团块——一点也不像滑溜溜的鱿鱼圈。
Oh, they're very scraggly-looking.
哦，看起来非常破烂。
But then, as if by a miracle, they changed. My sister gave a shake to the fry basket. And as they sizzled, the bung just seemed to gracefully snap into rings.
但随后，奇迹般地，它们变了。我妹妹摇了摇油炸篮。当它们滋滋作响时，直肠似乎优雅地弹成了圆圈。
Oh, look at that, though. It's like magic. They're turning into circles.
哦，看那个。就像魔法一样。它们变成了圆圈。
Yeah. So I'm going to pull these first ones.
是的。所以我打算把第一批捞出来。
Soon, we were face to face with the plate. On it, there were two piles of rings, similar in size, similar in shape. The bung had more of a frizzly edge to it, kind of like a fancy onion ring. The calamari was smoother. I asked Seth and Brian to just give a first impression.
很快，我们就面对着盘子。上面有两堆圈，大小相似，形状相似。直肠的边缘更卷曲，有点像高级洋葱圈。鱿鱼更光滑。我请塞斯和布莱恩给个第一印象。
I have a guess. But I could-- it's one the things where you're pretty sure, but you could totally be wrong.
我有猜测。但我可以——这是那种你很确定但完全可能搞错的事情之一。
God, I thought I would be more sure. I don't-- I'm waffling now.
天哪，我以为我会更确定。我不知道——我现在在动摇。
It's kind of just, I don't know.
我不知道。
My gut reaction-- my gut reaction is that this was calamari, and this was not.
我的直觉反应——我的直觉反应是这是鱿鱼，而这不是。
OK, before you eat it, see, I totally thought this was calamari, the other one.
好，在你吃之前，看，我完全以为这是鱿鱼，那个其他的。
OK.
好的。
So I'm going to do it at the same time.
所以我打算同时吃。
All right.
好吧。
OK, so just to be clear what's going on here, Seth has chosen one pile of rings, which he thinks is calamari. Brian has done the same thing, only Brian is choosing the other stack of fried rings.
好的，为了明确一下正在发生的事情，塞斯选了一堆圈，他认为是鱿鱼。布莱恩也做了同样的事，只是布莱恩选了另一堆炸圈。
OK, so we're about to bite into these simultaneously, which we both think this is calamari.
好的，我们要同时咬下去，我们俩都认为这是鱿鱼。
But they're the opposite ones.
但它们是相反的。
But they're the opposite ones. OK.
但它们是相反的。好的。
[CRUNCHING]
[咀嚼声]
So in actuality, Seth is right. Seth is eating calamari. The chewing you hear from Brian's mic, that is the sound of a calamari lover eating fried pig rectum.
所以实际上，塞斯是对的。塞斯在吃鱿鱼。你从布莱恩麦克风里听到的咀嚼声，是一个鱿鱼爱好者在吃油炸猪直肠。
I should also add, there were actually two varieties of bung on the plate that day. One bung that my sister had blanched over and over to mellow any organy fecal flavor, and then untreated, straight-up bung, unfiltered, unchained, uncut, 100% pure bung. That one, the latter one, bung at its purest, at the height of its bunginess, this is what Brian was eating. As they ate, Seth still looked confident.
我也应该补充一点，盘子里实际上有两种直肠。一种是我妹妹漂烫了很多次以缓和任何脏器排泄物味道的直肠，另一种是未经处理、直接使用的直肠，不过滤、无拘无束、未经切割，100%纯净直肠。后者，那种最纯粹、处于直肠巅峰状态的直肠，就是布莱恩在吃的。当他们吃的时候，塞斯看起来依然很自信。
I think that was-- I think I was right.
我觉得那是——我觉得我是对的。
I think I was right.
我觉得我是对的。
Really?
真的吗？
[LAUGHS] Yeah. I totally think I was right.
[笑声] 是的。我完全觉得我是对的。
Game, set, match, bung. And it wasn't just Brian. I thought so. Damian, who manages the restaurant, he also thought it was passable. A few of us picked up a faint flavor of pork rind. But if you weren't really looking for it, you wouldn't notice it was there.
比赛结束，直肠获胜。而且不仅仅是布莱恩。我也这么认为。负责管理餐厅的达米安（Damian），他也认为是可以接受的。我们中有几个人闻到了一丝猪皮味。但如果你不是真的在寻找它，你不会注意到它的存在。
One of the restaurant staff, a guy named Ethan Van Buren, had the simplest, clearest explanation.
餐厅员工之一，一个叫伊森·范·布伦（Ethan Van Buren）的人，给出了最简单、最清晰的解释。
I think that when you slice something up really thin and deep fry it, it's going to taste like something that's been deep fried.
我觉得当你把东西切得非常薄然后油炸时，它尝起来就像油炸的东西。
If a plateful of the bung came out, how many people do you think would even-- do you think you'd notice if you were in that setting?
如果端上来一盘直肠，你觉得有多少人会——你觉得你在那种环境会注意到吗？
I'd say top scenario is somebody says, this calamari tastes funny, and keeps eating it.
我会说最好的情况是有人说，这个鱿鱼尝起来有点怪，然后继续吃。
And as for Brian-- oh, Brian-- Brian was reeling a bit, trying to figure out just what this was going to mean for him.
而布莱恩——哦，布莱恩——布莱恩有点崩溃，试图弄清楚这对意味着什么。
I'm sure I've been fooled in the past. I'm just, like, sure of it.
我肯定我过去被骗过。我只是，就像，确定。
Oh, you're thinking that you've been places in the past, and you've had bung?
哦，你是在想你过去去过什么地方，然后吃了直肠？
I just imagine seeing a plate with this food that looks like this on it, sitting with my family growing up. We definitely have eaten something that tasted like this and just thought it was calamari, for sure.
我只是想象着看到一盘看起来像这样的食物放在上面，和我家人一起长大。我们绝对吃过尝起来像这样的东西，而且肯定以为是鱿鱼。
Not only wasn't he sure if he'd ever eat calamari again, he didn't want to eat the calamari on the plate in front of him, calamari I guaranteed him was real.
他不确定自己是否还会再吃鱿鱼，而且他不想吃面前盘子里的鱿鱼，我向他保证那是真的。
Just to repeat one last time, I have no proof that anyone, anywhere has ever tried to pass off pork bung as calamari in a restaurant. All I know is if you wanted to do it, it would be easy. And I'm choosing to believe that it's happening somewhere, because at some point in working on this story, I stopped identifying with Brian and anyone who might feel ripped off or grossed out by getting imitation instead of the real thing. Now, I identify with the bung.
最后再重复一遍，我没有证据证明任何人、在任何地方曾试图在餐馆里把猪直肠当成鱿鱼卖。我只知道如果你想这样做，这很容易。而且我选择相信它在某处正在发生，因为在制作这个故事的过程中，我不再认同布莱恩或任何可能觉得被坑或因为吃到赝品而不是真品而感到恶心的人。现在，我认同直肠。
And I'd like to think that somewhere out there, right now, under a heat lamp, a platter is sitting. It's warm, and it's full of promise, and transformation, and redemption. That's the world that I'll choose to live in, for me, for you, for the bung, for the bung in all of us.
我想认为在某处的某个地方，现在，在热灯下，放着一盘菜。它是热的，充满希望、转变和救赎。那就是我选择居住的世界，为了我，为了你，为了直肠，为了我们每个人体内的直肠。
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers of our program. Ladies and gentlemen, before you swear off calamari forever, please, please notice that Ben is only saying that it is possible that this is happening, that he did not find actual documented proof that pig bung is being substituted for calamari, abroad or especially here in the United States.
本·卡尔霍恩是我们节目的制片人之一。女士们先生们，在你们发誓永远不吃鱿鱼之前，请务必注意，本只是在说这种情况“可能”发生，他并没有找到关于猪直肠在国外，或特别是在美国被替换为鱿鱼的实际记录证明。
Coming up, cooking chicken for dinner right in front of the chicken who is your pet, who you live with, who watches you do it. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，在你作为宠物、与你同住、看着你做饭的鸡面前烹饪鸡肉。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, turkey and a face mask. For the holiday season, this unusual COVID Thanksgiving, when so many things about the holiday are different, we put together a show with stories about food that we have done over the years. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "Still Life with Chicken."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“火鸡与口罩”。在节日季节，在这个如此多的事情与以往不同的新冠感恩节，我们整理了一期节目，讲述我们多年来制作过的关于食物的故事。我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“鸡肉静物”。
So Jonathan Gold was a kind of legendary food writer, invented this way of writing about restaurants that treated hole-in-the-wall places and street food with the same seriousness that other restaurant critics had always written about fancy places. This led to a whole genre of food writing and TV shows, like Anthony Bourdain.
乔纳森·戈尔德（Jonathan Gold）是一位传奇美食作家，他发明了一种描写餐馆的方式，将那些深巷小店和街头小吃与那些复杂的餐馆评论家一直以来描写高档场所的笔调一样严肃地对待。这引出了一整套美食写作和电视节目类型，比如安东尼·波登（Anthony Bourdain）。
And before he died in 2018, Jonathan was on our show a couple times. And this interview that I want to play you now, it was one of those conversations that just-- it ended in a very different place than it began, as you'll hear. It ended with him talking about-- I don't even know how exactly what to call it-- but the nature of eating. But it began with Jonathan explaining to me how he ended up living with a chicken. He explained that that happened by accident. When he was in his 20s, he was not living the kind of life one usually associates with chickens.
在2018年去世前，乔纳森上过我们的节目几次。我想播放的这段采访，那是那种——最终走向了一个与开始时截然不同地方的谈话，正如你将听到的。它结束于谈论——我甚至不知道该怎么确切定义它——但它是关于饮食的本质。但它开始于乔纳森向我解释他最终是如何与一只鸡住在一起的。他解释说那是偶然发生的。在他20多岁时，他过着那种通常不会与鸡联系在一起的生活。
This was during the period when I considered myself to be a performance artist of sort-- a naked performance artist, to be specific.
那是在我自认为是某种表演艺术家的时期——具体来说，是裸体表演艺术家。
He was putting together a performance. He had a PA system, which could put out the requisite amount of annoying feedback sound at high decibels. He had the two full bottles of Glade American Beauty air freshener, which he would spray in their entirety in the performance space. And he had a live chicken, which he bought the day before the performance from one of those Chinese poultry markets in Los Angeles.
他正在策划一场表演。他有一个扩音系统，可以发出高分贝所需的恼人反馈声。他有两整瓶“Glade”美国之美空气清新剂，他会在表演场地把它们喷完。他还有一只活鸡，是他前一天从洛杉矶那些中国活禽市场买来的。
And comes the day of the show, an audience gathers in a darkened warehouse in West LA.
表演当天，观众聚集在西洛杉矶的一个黑暗仓库里。
I don't know if you've been to a lot of performance art, but this was sort of really typical of the stuff that was going on in the period. And I showed up. And I was naked. And I was carrying a machete. And I was blindfolded.
我不知道你有没有看过很多行为艺术，但这就属于那个时期非常典型的表演。我出现了。我是裸体的。我手里拿着一把砍刀。而且我被蒙住了眼睛。
And I stood in the middle of this pile of supermarket chickens, like the broilers that you buy. And the chicken that I had bought was tethered to a 3-foot rope around me. And I hacked up and down blindly with a machete.
我站在一堆超市买来的鸡中间，就像你买的那种肉鸡。我买的那只鸡被拴在一条3英尺长的绳子上，拴在我身上。我盲目地用砍刀乱砍。
Toward the chicken, or just in general?
冲着鸡，还是只是随意砍？
Well, I was blindfolded, so I didn't know if it was towards the chicken or not.
嗯，我被蒙住了眼睛，所以我不知道是不是冲着鸡。
And I had fully intended that, in fact, I would kill the chicken in the midst of the performance. But chickens aren't that stupid. And this chicken wanted no part of the machete. It stayed at the end of its rope the entire time, apparently. And after 10 minutes, when I was completely exhausted, I fell to a heap. And everybody laughed, and the performance was over.
我完全打算在表演中杀掉那只鸡。但鸡并不那么蠢。这只鸡一点都不想参与这场砍刀表演。显然，它全程都待在绳子的末端。10分钟后，我精疲力竭，倒在了一堆里。每个人都在笑，表演结束了。
I don't know if you've stuck around after an art performance. But the few minutes after an art performance are some of the most depressing in the world.
我不知道你在艺术表演后有没有留下来过。但在艺术表演后的几分钟是世界上最令人沮丧的时刻。
How so?
怎么讲？
You've done your wad. You've done your sort of bid for art, which has either worked, or it hasn't. But you're sitting there. You're covered with chicken eflluvia, in my case. It stinks to high hell. Everybody's gone. And you've got to clean up. And you're naked.
你已经用尽了你的全力。你已经进行了你的艺术尝试，要么成功了，要么没成功。但你坐在那里。你身上沾满了鸡的排泄物，在我的案例中。臭得要死。所有人都走了。你还得清理。而且你是裸体的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
It's really not a pretty picture.
这画面真的不太美观。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
So Jonathan cleaned up. And when he was done, he had a chicken. And he didn't feel like he could kill the chicken. Destiny had brought them together. He felt like he could not turn his back. He says it was the same as if a kitten shows up on your back door, scratching, and lonely, needy. So he took the chicken home.
于是乔纳森清理干净了。当他做完时，他还有一只鸡。他觉得他不忍心杀掉这只鸡。命运把他们凑在了一起。他觉得他不能背弃它。他说这就像一只小猫出现在你的后门，挠着门，孤独、需要关怀。所以他把鸡带回了家。
And in doing that, he stumbled across that thin, thin line that separates food items on the one hand from pets on the other, that divides the animals we eat from the animals we love.
在这样做时，他偶然发现了那条将一方面的食物与另一方面的宠物分开的细细界线，划分了我们吃的动物与我们爱的动物。
So I get home, and I have this chicken. And I don't know what to do with it. So I spread out some newspaper on the top of my refrigerator, and I put the chicken up there. I get a can of Green Giant-brand niblets from under the counter, and I open it. And I put it in a little bowl for the chicken. And I give the chicken a little water. And the chicken's on top of my refrigerator.
所以回到家，我有了这只鸡。我不知道该怎么办。于是我在冰箱顶上铺了一些报纸，把鸡放了上去。我从柜台下拿出一罐“绿巨人”牌玉米粒，把它打开。我给鸡放在一个小碗里。我给鸡一点水。于是鸡就待在我的冰箱顶上。
Because you think chickens eat corn-- you had read that or something-- and that was the available corn.
因为你觉得鸡吃玉米——你读过这个或者别的什么——而那是手边现有的玉米。
That was the available corn. I wish I had thought better of the niblets idea.
那是手边现有的玉米。我真希望当时能对玉米粒这个点子有更好的想法。
Why?
为什么？
Because, in fact, if you're buying three or four cans of niblets a day, which is what the chicken ate, and you're existing on almost nothing, which I was, then your niblet bill turns out to be like some two-figure percentage of your total income each week.
因为，事实上，如果你每天买三四罐玉米粒，这就是那只鸡吃的量，而你几乎靠什么都不吃过活，我当时就是这样，那么你的玉米粒账单每周竟然占你总收入的两位数百分比。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
If you imagine living on $50 a week, but $10 of it goes for niblets.
如果你想象每周靠50美元生活，但其中10美元用于买玉米粒。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
It's just hard to justify an expense like that.
这种支出真的很难证明其合理性。
Though, at the remove 15 years, I think I can probably safely admit to you now that one of the reasons that I stuck with niblets is because I like saying the word niblet so much.
虽然，在15年后，我觉得我大概可以安全地承认了，我坚持用玉米粒的原因之一是因为我太喜欢说“niblet”（玉米粒）这个词了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
And this gave me the excuse to use the words, like niblet, in general conversation several times a day.
这给了我借口在日常对话中每天多次使用“niblet”这样的词。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Usually, it just doesn't come up.
通常情况下，这根本不会被提到。
And the chicken stayed there on top of my refrigerator for a long time-- months. Six months, I think.
那只鸡在那儿——在我的冰箱顶上待了很长时间——几个月。我想有六个月。
Is this like a one-room apartment?
这是那种一居室公寓吗？
A two-room apartment. I had a kitchen and a bedroom. So I didn't have to look at the chicken when I was sleeping, though I did have to look at it when I was cooking.
两居室公寓。我有一个厨房和一个卧室。所以我睡觉的时候不用看着那只鸡，尽管我在做饭的时候确实得看着它。
Did you ever cook chicken?
你吃过鸡肉吗？
Of course, I cooked chicken.
当然，我做过鸡肉。
Didn't you feel intensely disloyal?
你不觉得非常不忠诚吗？
No, I felt no particular loyalty to this chicken. I don't know if you've ever had chickens, but it's not like-- you don't pet chickens. Chickens don't really like you to pet them, and you don't hold them. There's really no love that you feel for a chicken in your life, I don't think.
不，我对这只鸡没有特别的忠诚。我不知道你有没有养过鸡，但它不像——你不会抚摸鸡。鸡真的不喜欢你摸它们，你也不会抱着它们。我不认为你在生活中对鸡会有什么爱。
But yet, you kept the chicken.
但你还是留下了这只鸡。
I kept the chicken because I couldn't bear to do anything else. And it's not like I could have carried it out onto Pico Boulevard and said, be free, little chicken. Be free.
我留下这只鸡是因为我不忍心做别的。而且这也不是说我可以把它带到皮科大道（Pico Boulevard）上说，自由吧，小鸡。自由吧。
Did you give the chicken a name?
你给鸡起名字了吗？
I never named the chicken. When I referred to the chicken in public, I always called it "the hen."
我从来没给鸡起过名字。当我在公共场合提到这只鸡时，我总是叫它“那只母鸡”。
How did you not name it? It was a creature in your house.
你怎么可能没给它起名？它是在你家里的生物。
The chicken always seemed temporary. It never occurred to me that I might have the chicken as long as six months. The chicken always seemed like something that I would have for just a couple days.
这只鸡看起来总是暂时的。我从未想过我会养这只鸡长达六个月。这只鸡看起来总是那种我只会养几天的事物。
And then what did you think was going to happen?
那你当时想会发生什么？
I guess I thought-- A, I thought about the chicken expiring. B, I have to admit that there was a possibility that someday, I would actually cook the chicken. I went through a lot of chicken recipes, hundreds and hundreds of chicken recipes. But--
我猜我想——A，我想过这只鸡会死亡。B，我必须承认有一天我真的会做这只鸡的可能性。我浏览过很多鸡肉食谱，成百上千份鸡肉食谱。但是——
Thinking, maybe this will be the recipe for my niblet-fed chicken?
心想，也许这就是那份为我那只吃玉米粒长大的鸡准备的食谱？
Exactly.
正是如此。
Possibly-- I have to say it-- the most delicious chicken that you could ever eat because of those niblets.
可能——我必须说出来——这是你能吃过的最美味的鸡肉，因为那些玉米粒。
You can't buy niblet-fed chicken, for love or money, I don't think.
我不认为你花多少钱能买到吃玉米粒长大的鸡。
I'm not sure that a recipe existed that would have lived up to the fact of the chicken, this animal who you have come to know on fairly intimate terms, and who you have raised, and who you have put a certain amount of emotion into.
我不确定是否存在一份食谱能配得上这只鸡，这只你已经相当亲近，并且养大，投入了某种情感的动物。
A chicken, if I might say, who has seen you naked.
一只，我能否说，见过你裸体的鸡。
The chicken did see me naked, dammit.
那只鸡确实见过我裸体，该死的。
The fact is, we need food to be just food. And as soon as it becomes a living thing, especially if we're city people-- we're not used to the conversion of living things into our food-- it's hard to handle without thinking it has to be bigger than food, without wanting to make it ritualized or something bigger than food.
事实是，我们需要食物仅仅作为食物。而一旦它变成了一种生命，尤其是如果我们是城市居民——我们不习惯将生命转化为我们的食物——如果不想得太多，或者不把它仪式化，不赋予它比食物更重要的意义，就很难处理。
Exactly. Could I tell you a short-- a small story?
正是。我能给你讲个简短的——一个小故事吗？
Yeah, of course.
当然可以。
A few weeks ago, I was in this Korean restaurant in Koreatown in Los Angeles. It was this place called The Living Fish Center that I'd always wanted to go, because the name of it was so splendid, Living Fish Center. I imagined some sort of vast vivarium where Flipper was jumping through hoops and stuff.
几周前，我在洛杉矶韩国城的一家韩国餐馆。那是叫“活鱼中心”（The Living Fish Center）的地方，我一直想去，因为名字太赞了，“活鱼中心”。我想象着某种巨大的生态缸，弗利普（Flipper）在那里跳过呼啦圈之类的东西。
And I go in there. And of course, it's just like a crummy Korean restaurant. It's not that clean. And I don't know-- there are tanks and stuff, but I didn't know what to order. So I order a fish soup, because it looks like they have a small fish soup specialty on the menu. And it comes, and it's just really strong-smelling, not that great. And I try squid fried with bean sauce and onions, which wasn't that happening.
我进去，当然，它就像一家破烂的韩国餐馆。不太干净。我不知道——有很多鱼缸什么的，但我不知道点什么。于是我点了一份鱼汤，因为菜单上看起来他们有鱼汤特色菜。端上来后，味道太冲了，不太好。我尝试了豆酱洋葱炒鱿鱼，也不怎么样。
And I'm about to give up, and pay the check, and go home with a vast table filled with uneaten stuff. And it suddenly occurs to me what the specialty of the restaurant is. And I wave the waitress over, and I tell her that I'd like a prawn. And she is puzzled. She didn't expect me to ask for a prawn. But I repeat my request, and she shrugs, and goes, and tells the sushi chef.
我正要放弃，准备结账回家，桌上堆满了没吃的东西。突然想到那家餐馆的特色是什么。我挥手叫来服务员，告诉她我想要一只虾。她很困惑。她没想到我会点虾。但我重复了我的要求，她耸耸肩，去告诉了寿司厨师。
And he goes to one side of the restaurant. He climbs on this chair, this ordinary folding chair, and he reaches into this long tank that's running just below the ceiling. And he wiggles his fingers in the water. When he wiggles the fingers, the prawns just become enraged and they start nipping at his fingers, and they start attacking him. And he picks out a couple of the liveliest ones and brings them back to his counter, and-- without washing his hands, mind you-- just makes a few motions over it. And a couple seconds later, the waitress comes over with the prawns on this huge mound of ice.
他走到餐馆的一侧。他爬上一把椅子，那种普通的折叠椅，伸进天花板下方运行的长鱼缸里。他在水里动了动手指。当他动手指时，虾立刻狂怒起来，开始咬他的手指，它们开始攻击他。他挑了几只最活跃的，带回到他的柜台——注意，没洗手——只是在上面做了几个动作。几秒钟后，服务员端着放在一大堆冰上的虾过来了。
Now, what he'd done is he'd taken off the exoskeleton. He'd essentially-- the head was intact. And that little part of the tail that is always on prawns is still there. But the middle part is naked, like a grub. And I picked up the prawn with my chopsticks. And it was not dead, this prawn. It was extremely alive. And it was wiggling its legs, and it was wiggling its antennas. And its eyes were swiveling madly on its eye stalks. And it was looking back at me, seeing me as actually the predator, the creature that was going to eat it.
现在，他做的是去掉了外骨架。他本质上——头部完好无损。虾身上总是有的尾巴那一小部分还在。但中间部分是赤裸的，像个幼虫。我用筷子夹起虾。这只虾并没有死。它非常活跃。它在摆动腿，在摆动触须。它的眼睛在眼柄上疯狂地转动。它回看着我，视我为真正的捕食者，要吃掉它的生物。
And that was a really freakish moment, because as much stuff as I eat, and as low as I eat on the food chain, and as many prawns as I have dispatched in my life, I have never before killed a living being with my teeth. And the prawn knew what I was going to do, and he did not like it.
那是一个非常怪异的时刻，因为尽管我吃了很多东西，尽管我在食物链中吃得很低，尽管我一生中处理过那么多虾，但我从未用牙齿杀死过一个活生生的生物。那只虾知道我要做什么，而它并不喜欢。
And I wasn't quite sure what to do. But if I put it down, the prawn would have died anyway. It's not going to live without its shell, and somebody else would have eaten it, blah, blah, blah. So I bit into it. I bit its body off with my teeth. And the prawn just relaxed in this way that was really eerie.
我不知道该怎么办。但如果我把它放下，虾无论如何都会死。没有外壳它活不了，别人也会吃掉它，诸如此类。于是我咬了下去。我用牙齿咬断了它的身体。那只虾就那样放松了，那种方式真的很诡异。
And the taste of the prawn, the taste of the meat of it was extraordinary. It was sweet. It was like there was life coursing through it. It was the most alive thing I've ever eaten, obviously literally. But again, it was freaky. It was getting too close to the actual nature of consumption, which is killing a living creature with your teeth.
那种虾的味道，肉的味道，太特别了。它是甜的。就像生命在其中流淌一样。这显然是我吃过的最活的东西，字面意思上。但再次强调，它是怪异的。它太接近消费的真实本质了，也就是用牙齿杀死一个活着的生物。
When you bit into the prawn, did you actually bite off its head, its living head, and have its head and its eyes in your mouth?
当你咬进虾肉时，你是真的咬掉了它的头，它活着的头，然后它的头和眼睛在你嘴里吗？
No, I bit off its body, and I held the head in my hands.
不，我咬掉了它的身体，我手里拿着它的头。
So you held the head in one hand and the tail in the other, and you bit the center?
所以你一手拿着头，一手拿着尾巴，然后咬中间？
Right. And I thought that I'd killed it. But in fact, when I put it down, it still had so much life in it that it grabbed a piece of salmon sashimi and wouldn't let go of it. And I don't think I ever want to do that again.
对。我以为我杀了它。但事实上，当我把它放下时，它依然拥有如此多的生命力，它抓住了另一块三文鱼刺身并不放手。我不觉得我以后还想那样做。
Did you feel like there was something about the experience that made it more-- this word is a little cornier than I intend, but it's the only word that I can think of-- that made it more sacred, that took it out of the mundaneness of the way that we eat, which, for most of us, is eating without actually tasting, and experiencing, and thinking about what we're eating, and what on the Earth it is that we're killing to survive?
你是否觉得这种体验让它变得更——这个词比我想表达的要陈腐，但这是我能想到的唯一词——让它变得更神圣，让它脱离了我们饮食那种平凡的方式，那种对大多数人来说，就是不假思索地吃，不体验，不思考我们正在吃什么，为了生存我们正在杀死地球上的什么？
Do you think in some way that it's more acceptable to eat an animal if you are more awake to the fact that it is an animal and what's happened to it? Or do you think it really doesn't matter?
你认为在某种程度上，如果你更清醒地意识到它是一种动物，以及它经历了什么，那么吃它是更可接受的吗？还是你觉得这真的无所谓？
I think it matters a great deal. One of the greatest metaphors in Western civilization is that of Christ, who gave his life so that others might live. And I don't want to be sacrilegious, and I don't want to belittle that myth in any way.
我认为这非常重要。西方文明中最伟大的隐喻之一是基督的隐喻，他献出自己的生命以便他人能活着。我不想亵渎，我也不想以任何方式贬低那个神话。
But a pig is giving its life so that we might eat. A chicken is giving its life so that we might eat. And I think the least that we can do is to think about that chicken, to think about that calf that we're eating. Not necessarily to be sad for it, but to celebrate it, to be aware of the being that it was, that it wasn't just this bit of bioengineered protein that somehow managed to find its way onto our plates.
但一只猪献出生命以便我们能吃。一只鸡献出生命以便我们能吃。我认为我们至少能做的是思考那只鸡，思考我们正在吃的那个小牛。不一定是为它感到悲伤，而是庆祝它，意识到它曾经是一个生命，它不仅仅是某种设法出现在我们盘子里的生物工程蛋白质。
Jonathan Gold. If you're curious about his writing, there's collection of his columns called Counter Intelligence.
乔纳森·戈尔德。如果你对他的写作感到好奇，有一本他的专栏集叫做《反情报》（Counter Intelligence）。
Act Three, "Lunchtime with the King of Ketchup." So we end our show today with the story of a man who has a very simple mission in life, to give a little special treatment to a group of people whose contribution to society is often overlooked, the men and women of the food service industry, who, when they meet this guy, tend to give him a little special treatment in return.
第三幕，“与番茄酱之王一起吃午餐”。我们今天节目的结尾讲述了一个男人，他一生有一个非常简单的使命：给一群社会贡献常被忽视的人一点特殊对待，那就是食品服务行业的男男女女，当他们遇到这个家伙时，往往会反过来给他一点特殊对待。
This story, as you'll be able to tell when you hear it, was first broadcast long before the pandemic. Jonathan Goldstein-- whose name I know is very similar to the guy in Act Two, but that means nothing-- tells the tale.
正如你们听到时就会知道的那样，这个故事早在疫情之前就播出了。乔纳森·戈尔茨坦（Jonathan Goldstein）——我知道他的名字和第二幕里的那个人很像，但这毫无意义——讲述了这个故事。
Howard Chackowicz and I have been friends since we're kids. And so I can say with great authority that almost every day for the past 10 years, Howard Chackowicz has either dined out or ordered in at least one of his meals.
我和霍华德·查科维茨（Howard Chackowicz）从小就是朋友。所以我可以以极大的权威说，过去10年几乎每一天，霍华德·查科维茨要么外出就餐，要么叫外卖，至少有一餐是这样。
Sometimes, when Howard isn't sure what he's in the mood for, he'll lift an empty hand up to his mouth and pretend that he's eating. He stares straight ahead, trying to figure out if he likes the taste of the imaginary food he's shoving into his mouth. Sometimes, his hand is holding a hamburger. Sometimes, a fork wrapped in spaghetti. And other times, he is double-fisting either end of an invisible pork rib.
有时，当霍华德不确定自己想吃什么时，他会把空着的手举到嘴边，假装在吃东西。他直视前方，试图弄清楚自己是否喜欢那种塞进嘴里的想象食物的味道。有时，他的手里拿着汉堡。有时，是一叉子意大利面。而其他时候，他双手握着看不见的猪肋排的两端。
Howard's always loved restaurants. He was raised in a Jewish Eastern-European household, where the very idea of a restaurant was a ridiculous piece of decadence, something for Cossacks and cocaine addicts who enjoyed flushing their money down the toilet. Restaurants had a transgressive allure. And as soon as Howard was old enough, he started sneaking away to them after school or sometimes on weekends while the whole family was still asleep.
霍华德一直很喜欢餐馆。他在一个犹太东欧家庭长大，在那里，去餐馆的概念简直是荒谬的颓废，是给那些喜欢把钱冲进马桶的哥萨克人和可卡因瘾君子准备的。餐馆有一种越界的诱惑力。霍华德一长大，就开始在放学后或有时在全家人还在睡觉的周末溜出去。
In fact, Howard was the very first person I've ever dined out with alone, without any family. We were 12 years old, and we ate at Atomics Pizzeria, a place just down the street from us. It was owned by a crotchety old Greek man named Costa, who served ridiculously large portions of food.
事实上，霍华德是我第一个单独外出就餐而不带任何家人的伙伴。我们12岁时，在离我们街道不远的“Atomics Pizzeria”餐馆吃饭。那是一家由一个叫科斯塔（Costa）的古怪希腊老头拥有的店，他提供大得离谱的食物份量。
We'd get a plate of fries the size of a dead Shetland pony. But right alongside of it, Costa would place one measly packet of ketchup. When we asked for more, he looked at us like we had just asked for more blood from his mother's still beating heart. Whereas I learned to ration, eating 400 to 500 French fries with a bottle-cap-sized dollop, Howard learned how to talk to Costa, how to win him over, how to make him see that giving us more ketchup was just the right thing to do.
我们本来可以得到一盘死设得兰小马那么大的薯条。但就在它旁边，科斯塔只会放一小包番茄酱。当我们想要更多时，他看着我们，就像我们刚要他母亲那颗还在跳动的心脏献血一样。虽然我学会了配给，用瓶盖大小的一点酱吃掉400到500根薯条，霍华德却学会了如何与科斯塔交谈，如何赢得他，如何让他意识到给我们更多番茄酱是正确的做法。
Along the way, Howard learned how to say in Greek, thank you, kind sir, bless you for the ketchup, as well as the excellent [SPEAKING GREEK] ketchup sauce-- here's many years to your ketchup.
在这个过程中，霍华德学会了如何用希腊语说谢谢，仁慈的先生，保佑你给的番茄酱，以及优秀的[希腊语]番茄酱——这里有多年给你的番茄酱。
Ever since way back then, Howard has had a very special rapport with the men and women of the food service industry. And he has worked very hard over the years to cultivate this relationship.
从那时起，霍华德就与食品服务行业的男男女女建立了非常特殊的关系。多年来，他一直非常努力地培养这种关系。
This is my neighborhood here. I've been to every single restaurant in this neighborhood several times, so I feel like I can call in on every restaurant.
这是我的社区。我已经去过这个社区里的每一家餐馆好几次了，所以我感觉我可以随时打给任何一家餐馆。
A couple of weeks ago, Howard took me on a walking tour of the best places to eat in his neighborhood. I've walked into bakeries with Howard where the young girls and old men alike who work there have dropped their doughnut tongs to cry out with joy, Howard! I've watched him get moved to the front of the line outside restaurants in Chinatown.
几周前，霍华德带我进行了他社区最佳餐馆的步行游。我曾和霍华德走进过面包店，在那里工作的年轻女孩和老人都放下了甜甜圈钳子，欢呼着喊道：“霍华德！”我看着他在唐人街餐馆外的队伍被移到最前面。
When he's relating to a waiter or a deliveryman, all that Howard sees is one person giving another person food. He talks to them as though they are friends-- brothers, even. His servers are able to sense his purity of vision, and they bestow on him, in every exchange, some little bit of special treatment.
当他与服务员或外卖员交流时，霍华德看到的只是一个人给另一个人食物。他跟他们说话，就像他们是朋友——甚至是兄弟。他的服务员能够感知到他纯粹的愿景，并在每一次交流中赋予他一点点特殊对待。
Well, let me just show you a ghost here. On the corner there is a place called-- I'm not sure what that is. That used to be called Le Defi, which is The Challenge. And that was a really great place. And then they closed and they moved right across the street. And they had $1.99 spaghetti meal. I would go there every day, and I brought a lot of friends. But I got so-- it got to the point where, when I came in, I was actually able to serve myself.
好吧，让我给你展示一个幽灵。角落里有一个地方叫——我不确定那叫什么。那过去叫“Le Defi”，意思是“挑战”。那是个真的很棒的地方。然后他们关门了，搬到了街对面。他们有1.99美元的意大利面套餐。我每天都去那里，带了很多朋友。但我变得如此——甚至到了那种程度，当我进去时，我实际上可以自助了。
That's how close we got. We'd go in. They'd greet me, and they wouldn't even get up. I would go, and I would pour myself coffee. And I would actually serve other people coffee. I would say, more coffee, sir? At first, it was a novelty. But then they got very used to it and they actually liked it. The other funny thing is, too, one time, they actually made me-- let me make toast and stuff there, so make some of my food. That's actually a true story.
我们亲密到了这种程度。我们走进去。他们向我打招呼，甚至都不站起来。我会去给自己倒咖啡。我甚至会给其他人倒咖啡。我会说：“还要咖啡吗，先生？”起初，这是一种新奇的东西。但后来他们习惯了，实际上很喜欢。还有一件有趣的事情，有一次，他们真的让我——让我做烤面包之类的东西，所以做了一些我自己的食物。这实际上是一个真实的故事。
In fact, Howard is such a beloved figure in the neighborhood that whenever our friend, Tucker, goes into get takeout from Sarah's, a local Middle Eastern restaurant, he'll tell whoever is serving him that, in fact, the food was not for him, but that he was picking it up for Howard. This earned him portions that were almost twice as large as what he'd normally get. Howard, he is the best man, his server would say, as he piled food onto his plate. You are so lucky to have a friend like Howard. Indeed, he was.
事实上，霍华德是这个社区里一个如此受爱戴的人物，以至于每当我们的朋友塔克（Tucker）去“Sarah's”（一家当地的中东餐馆）买外卖时，他会告诉服务员，事实上食物不是给他的，而是他替霍华德买的。这为他赢得了比他通常能得到的几乎大两倍的份量。“霍华德，他是最好的人，”服务员会说，一边往他盘子里堆食物。“你有这样一个朋友真是太幸运了。”确实，他很幸运。
But the funny thing is is that Howard is so doted upon when he eats in restaurants that sometimes, it makes it difficult for him to just sit back and enjoy his meal. He feels he has to balance things out, and so he dotes right back. Because of that, it could be hard to carry on a conversation with him. His eyes will nervously scan the restaurant for any way he could be of help to the waiting staff. Howard's ears can detect the muted clink of cutlery falling to the carpet from clear across the room. And when he does, he'll do a kind of concerned gym-coach trot over to the mishandled piece of silverware and pluck it up off the floor.
但有趣的是，霍华德在餐馆吃饭时太受宠了，有时这使他难以安心享受餐点。他觉得他必须平衡一下，所以他也同样地回馈关爱。因为这样，和他交流可能会很困难。他的眼睛会紧张地扫描餐馆，寻找任何可以帮助服务人员的方法。霍华德的耳朵可以探测到餐具从房间对面落到地毯上的微弱叮当声。当他这么做时，他会进行一种关切的体育教练小跑，去捡起那个被弄掉的餐具。
So as much as Howard loves restaurants, when he really wants to relax, he'll get home delivery. And since it was nearing lunchtime, rather than step into one of the many restaurants we were passing, Howard ushered us back in the direction of his house to dial out for our grub. At his place, he pulled open his top kitchen drawer, and I saw the many choices that lay before us.
所以，尽管霍华德很喜欢餐馆，但当他真的想放松时，他会叫外卖。而且由于接近午餐时间，霍华德没有走进我们经过的众多餐馆中的一家，而是引导我们回到他的房子方向，拨打外卖号码。在他家，他拉开顶层厨房抽屉，我看到了摆在我们面前的众多选择。
There's about 400 menus in that drawer.
那个抽屉里大概有400份菜单。
I wouldn't say it's 400. I'd love to count it.
我不会说那是400份。我很想数一下。
Just give me an idea.
就给我一个概念。
I'd say if this handful is about 10-- 10, 20, 30, 40, 50, 60, 70--
我会说这一把大概是10份——10、20、30、40、50、60、70——
As much as restaurant owners and waiters love Howard, it's delivery men who really, really love him. Who among us even knows our delivery man's name? Howard knows their names and the names of their wives and children. When they come to his door, he invites them in and offers them water. And in return, they'll actually call Howard later on to see if his meal was to his liking, that it was warm enough, that there was enough ketchup.
尽管餐馆老板和服务员喜欢霍华德，但外卖员才是真正、真正喜欢他的人。我们当中有谁甚至知道外卖员的名字？霍华德知道他们的名字，以及他们妻子和孩子的名字。当他们来到他家门口时，他邀请他们进来并提供水。作为回报，他们实际上会晚点打给霍华德，看他的餐点是否合胃口，是否够热，番茄酱是否充足。
--190, 200-- this is very embarrassing-- 210, 220, 230, about 250 menus in here. There are some doubles, for sure, or even like multiple copies, but only restaurants I order from all the time.
——190、200——这太尴尬了——210、220、230，这里大概250份菜单。确实有一些双份，甚至多份副本，但只有我经常下单的餐馆。
We decide to order from Howard's favorite restaurant, a souvlaki place called The Greek Village.
我们决定从霍华德最喜欢的餐馆点餐，一家叫“希腊村”（The Greek Village）的烤肉店。
I'm going to take a number 10, the two-gyro pizza. And I think that's it Thanks. Have a nice day. Bye.
我要一份10号餐，两份烤肉串披萨。我想就是这样。谢谢。祝你有美好的一天。再见。
While we wait for the food, Howard waves me over and opens his kitchen cupboard to reveal physical proof of his good standing with the service industry.
当等待食物时，霍华德挥手叫我过去，打开他的厨房柜子，展示了他与服务业保持良好关系的实物证据。
Here we go. These are all bags of ketchup, salt, soy sauce.
来了。这些都是番茄酱、盐、酱油袋。
And this is all from takeout.
这些全都是外卖来的。
Yeah.
是的。
And these are big bags full of nothing but ketchup.
这些都是装满番茄酱的大袋子。
There's some soy sauce.
这里还有些酱油。
So gone are the days where you had to wheedle out a single packet out of Costa's hands for your French fries.
所以那种必须从科斯塔手里讨要一包番茄酱来配薯条的日子一去不复返了。
It's true that I have so much now, I have so many packets here. But no matter how many packets I amass, it'll never catch up to what I missed as a child, ketchup.
确实我现在有太多了，我有这么多包。但无论我积累了多少包，也永远追不上我小时候错过的番茄酱。
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
Then, with vaudeville timing, our delivery arrives.
然后，伴随着杂耍表演般的时机，我们的外卖到了。
Hey, Shamir.
嘿，沙米尔（Shamir）。
Howard greets the delivery man like an old friend he hasn't seen in quite some time.
霍华德像迎接一位好久不见的老朋友一样迎接外卖员。
Thanks so much, man.
太感谢了，伙计。
He's your friend. He's a beautiful man. He's such a nice man, I'm telling you.
他是你的朋友。他是个漂亮的人。他是个很好的人，我告诉你。
I didn't get you in trouble, though.
我没给你惹麻烦吧。
He's the best customer in Montreal I have.
他是我在蒙特利尔最好的客户。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Each time I come, he gave me apple. He give me a juice. He give me everything.
每次我来，他都给我苹果。他给我果汁。他给我所有东西。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
When I order in, like most people, I figure these guys want out of my house as badly as a bird that's accidentally flown in down the chimney. And I assist them in their passage, usually having the exact change with a tip all ready for them at the door. But at Howard's house, delivery men stay a long time. They seem to want to.
当我叫外卖时，像大多数人一样，我想这些家伙想从我家逃出去的心情，就像一只不小心从烟囱飞进来的鸟一样。我协助他们离开，通常在门口就准备好给他们的小费零钱。但在霍华德家，外卖员待很长时间。他们似乎愿意这样。
Shamir, can if I offer you something?
沙米尔，我能给你点什么吗？
No, thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
不用，谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。
Hey, so Marvin's not working there anymore?
嘿，所以马文不在那儿工作了吗？
No, because I think he find somewhere else a job.
没有，因为我想他去别处找了份工作。
Oh, OK. OK. I see everything is different. Actually, I felt so bad when I called, because when I ask, I say, Shamir, you know. They're like, well, we don't know who you're going to get.
哦，好的。好的。我看到一切都变了。实际上，当我打电话时我感到很糟，因为当我问时，我说，沙米尔，你知道。他们就像，嗯，我们不知道你会遇到谁。
Oh, you don't have to feel bad.
哦，你不必感到糟。
I know, but I don't want to get you in trouble.
我知道，但我不想给你惹麻烦。
After about 10 minutes of this, I just want to eat. I find myself eyeing the bag of souvlaki lying on the floor like a campground bear. I realize then that I'm just not made of the same stuff as Howard, and I never will be.
大约10分钟后，我只想吃东西。我发现自己像露营的熊一样盯着地上那一袋烤肉。我意识到那时候我根本不是和霍华德一样的人，而且永远也不会是。
When we finally sit down to eat, I can't even get Howard to admit that he's doing anything so special with guys like Shamir. We go back and forth on this.
当我们终于坐下来吃的时候，我甚至不能让霍华德承认他在像沙米尔这样的家伙身上做了什么特别的事。我们就这个问题争论来争论去。
Yeah, because most people won't go to the extent that you do, which is why you have guys that work the telephone coming by your house to meet you. That probably doesn't happen that often.
是的，因为大多数人不会做到你那种程度，这就是为什么会有专门接听电话的人专门到你家来见你。那可能不会经常发生。
Well, I really believe I don't really do anything. I'm nice to them.
嗯，我真的相信我没做什么。我只是对他们友好。
But just empirically, you have to see at this point that you're getting responded to differently than most people, so there must be something different, no?
但从经验来看，你必须看到在这一点上，你得到的反应与大多数人不同，所以肯定有什么不同的地方，对吧？
If someone's going to come to my door more than a few times, and they know my face, and we're saying, how are you, I'm going to start treating that person like a human being. And most people, I think, are probably rude to them. Most people that I know give deliveryman a buck. And I think that they do a hard-- they have a harder job than a waiter or a waitress because here's a guy who takes your food, gets into a car, risks his life, goes into traffic--
如果有人要来我家不止几次，而且他们认识我的脸，我们在说，你好吗，我会开始把那个人当作人类来对待。而大多数人，我认为，对他们可能是无礼的。我认识的大多数人给外卖员一美元。而且我认为他们做的是一份辛苦——他们比服务员或女服务员有更辛苦的工作，因为这是一个拿走你的食物，走进车里，冒着生命危险，走进交通流中的家伙——
Hang on a second? Risks his life?
等一下？冒着生命危险？
Oh he's driving a car, you know?
哦，他在开车，你知道吗？
Howard's worked all kinds of food service jobs himself-- as a waiter, a busboy, a short-order cook. And he says that as a result, he absolutely loathes the feeling of being served. There's something that just feels embarrassing and unnatural about it.
霍华德自己做过各种食品服务工作——作为服务员、收碗工、快餐厨师。他说结果就是，他绝对讨厌被服务的感觉。那种感觉简直尴尬且不自然。
But it even goes further than that. In his interactions with the service industry, he's looking for a particular feeling, a kind of cozy moment where he can palpably sense that the waiter has forgotten that he is a waiter and that they are both simply relating as human beings. And then once he knows this, once he knows they're both getting along and everyone's happy, he can move on. He isn't looking for anything else from them. His motives are pure that way.
但它甚至超越了这一点。在他的服务业互动中，他寻找一种特殊的感觉，一种舒适的时刻，在那里他可以明显感觉到服务员已经忘记了他是一名服务员，他们俩只是简单地作为人类在交往。然后一旦他知道这一点，一旦他知道他们相处得很好，每个人都很开心，他就可以继续做别的事。他不需要从他们那里得到任何其他东西。他的动机在这一点上是纯粹的。
But these kinds of special moments don't come without strings attached. And sometimes, Howard gets into trouble. Earlier in the day, during our walking tour, there was one place we didn't stop into, a little convenience store around the corner. Howard became uncharacteristically somber and quiet as we walked by the storefront window.
但这种特殊时刻并非没有附加条件。有时，霍华德会惹麻烦。当天早些时候，在我们步行游期间，有一个地方我们没进去，转角处的一家小便利店。当我们走过商店窗户时，霍华德变得非常阴沉和安静。
The owners, a Greek woman in her 60s named Voula and her older sister, used to be pretty friendly with him. Sometimes, Voula wouldn't charge him the tax on his chocolate bar. And on occasion, she'd have him sit behind the counter with her on a plastic milk crate. It wasn't much, but it was still more than what the other customers got. And it made Howard feel special. But then, at a certain point, things started to get more intense.
老板，一位60多岁的希腊女士名叫武拉（Voula）和她的姐姐，过去对他很友善。有时，武拉不会收他巧克力棒的税。偶尔，她还会让他坐在收银台后面，和他坐在一个塑料牛奶箱上。那不算什么，但依然比其他顾客得到的多。这让霍华德感到很特别。但后来，在某个点，事情开始变得更激烈了。
There had been several holdups there, by knifepoint, gunpoint. And I felt really bad for them. I'd see them really shook up. And they're kind of tough ladies, but they're alone. And I told them, I said, if you ever need anything, if there's any trouble or something, I'm just around the corner. You give me a call. And I really meant it like in case of emergency or just that there'd be someone they can call, some kind of community, some type of effort at community. But she started-- she would call every day.
那里发生过几次抢劫，用刀指着，用枪指着。我真的很同情她们。我看到她们真的被吓到了。她们是那种坚强的女士，但她们是孤独的。我告诉她们，我说，如果你们需要什么，如果有任何麻烦什么的，我就在转角。你们给我打电话。我真的意思是像在紧急情况下，或者仅仅是有个人可以给她们打电话，某种社区，某种社区努力。但她开始——她每天都打电话。
She would call him for all kinds of reasons, to have him come by and fix things or to run errands for her. And he would try his best to be accommodating. She'd even call him just to chat.
她会因为各种原因给他打电话，让他过来修理东西或者为她跑腿。他会尽最大努力去满足。她甚至打电话给他只是为了聊天。
Even though all of this was more than Howard could shoulder, he was reluctant to put an end to it. It was only after the calls got later into the night, at 1:00 and 2:00 in the morning, that Howard's friends started insisting he tell her that enough was enough. And against his better judgment, he did so. Howard wonders if it was right to give her his number in the first place.
尽管这一切都超过了霍华德能承担的范围，但他很不情愿结束它。只有在通话越来越晚，在凌晨1点和2点时，霍华德的朋友们才开始坚持让他告诉她够了就是够了。违背了他更好的判断，他这样做了。霍华德想知道一开始给她他的号码是否正确。
I made that offer assuming that it would be understood that there's a cutoff point. But to another person, that offer is a real, genuine offer. If I need help, I'm going to call you, and she did. And maybe she's the one that's right.
我做出那个提议时假设会有人理解有一个截止点。但对另一个人来说，那个提议是一个真实的、真诚的提议。如果我需要帮助，我会给你打电话，而她确实这样做了。也许她是那个正确的人。
So it's ironic that being nice to someone actually had the adverse effect, the opposite effect, and it ended up being a disaster. And now, two people are not even friendly with each other.
所以很讽刺的是，对某人友好实际上产生了相反的影响，相反的效果，结果成了一场灾难。现在，两个人甚至连朋友都不是了。
There have been other disasters for Howard, disasters where he was the one who went a little too far. Like there's the time he became so consumed with helping this neighborhood Chinese restaurant that, without being asked, he took it upon himself to draw up pamphlets for the place. The owner accepted Howard's flyers, but never circulated them. Later, the owner picked a screaming fight with Howard over an order, and Howard never went back.
霍华德还有过其他灾难，他做得有点过头的灾难。比如有一次他变得如此全神贯注于帮助这个社区中餐馆，以至于在没被要求的情况下，他自作主张为那个地方印了传单。老板接受了霍华德的传单，但从未分发过。后来，老板因为订单问题跟霍华德大吵了一架，霍华德再也没去过。
And then there was the time he brought in beautiful framed photos of Lebanon to his favorite Lebanese restaurant so they could be reminded of home. But the photos were never hung up, nor were they ever referred to again.
还有一次他把自己最喜欢的黎巴嫩餐馆带去了漂亮的黎巴嫩装帧照片，以便他们能被提醒家乡。但这些照片从未挂起来，也没再被提起过。
But for Howard, those things don't matter, and I know that he'd probably even do them all again. There are so many other moments that make his good intentions feel repaid in full. Some of his favorites are when deliverymen he knows pass him by in their cars as he's walking down the street. It shocks him out of his reverie when they honk their horns in a quick, affectionate burst. For a brief moment, it feels like a reassuring slap on the back. Howard thinks to himself that they're the best, and it fills him with so much gratitude that if he had a pear or a peach in his coat pocket, he would wave them over and give it to them.
但对霍华德来说，那些事情不重要，我知道他大概甚至会再做一遍。有太多的其他时刻让他的良好意愿感到完全得到了回报。他最喜欢的一些时刻是，当他走在街上，认识的外卖员开着车经过他时。当他们快速、充满感情地按响喇叭时，让他从幻想中震惊过来。在那一瞬间，感觉就像背上得到了一种令人安心的拍打。霍华德心想他们是最好的，这让他充满了感激，以至于如果他外套口袋里有一个梨或桃子，他会挥手叫他们过来，把水果给他们。
Jonathan Goldstein is the host of the podcast Heavyweight, which just finished its fifth season. I heartily recommend it. Great stories. You can hear it on Spotify or wherever else you get your podcasts.
乔纳森·戈尔茨坦是播客《Heavyweight》的主持人，刚刚完成了第五季。我衷心推荐它。很棒的故事。你可以在Spotify或任何你收听播客的地方收听。
Well, our program was produced today by Noor Gill, with mixing help from Stowe Nelson, Beth Blake, and Matt Tierney. Special thanks today to the restaurant Aurora in Brooklyn, who let us use the kitchen for our calamari taste test in Act One.
嗯，我们的节目今天由努尔·吉尔（Noor Gill）制作，斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、贝丝·布莱克（Beth Blake）和马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）提供了混音协助。今天特别感谢布鲁克林的Aurora餐馆，他们让我们在第一幕中把厨房用于我们的鱿鱼试吃测试。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can hear over 700 episodes of our program for absolutely free.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们节目超过700集。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, after a hard day at the radio station, as he heads home, he always turns and declares to all of us on his way out the door--
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。感谢，一如既往，我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）。你知道，在广播电台辛苦了一天后，当他回家时，他总是在出门前向我们所有人转过身宣布——
Man, I'm gonna eat me some bung tonight. That's just the way it is.
伙计，我今晚要吃点直肠。事实就是这样。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。